have you told your dog to behave he's
behaving he's the worst
he's all nice look oh he's got a little
hat okay stop stop his mind now no dog
he's not he's behaving now good good
kind of wish he attacked you for the
content well I was playing offline and
then accidentally dug your dog in a hole
and I was so sorry about you know
accidentally my dog would never attack
someone who did something by accident it
there's attacked me out of nothing I did
nothing you did that on purpose flea I
would never hit the dog purposefully you
did it purposely and epically ofbe I did
it or do we put metal cuz okay here in
our perfectly stored system Jack yeah
married and I know everything yeah help
me dude if you die in real life you die
in Minecraft
damn that's a sad bro let's change
perspective my life oh I don't like what
your dog is doing it's gonna hear Maya
he was my dog dude I don't know he's
looking at it where's mine
Maya ho what are you doing wait as yours
Maya here mines boy who or it's the
other way around I'm sorry I'm sorry
Hey look at that what do we name him
flip up of course how could I flop once
better chicken hands boy you wander
cheeky chicken was [ __ ] you know guests
dude he laid an egg we literally have a
chicken egg farm here and automated
change fun you're gonna give me the egg
I need the egg I want to show you a
trick I threw it at you and I miss I'm
just gonna throw it at you woah look at
that farm everything is grown I'll feed
the parents let him Frick yeah what are
we doing walking around again well we
have to update our stuff we had the farm
and yes there's nothing wrong with
walking around you know what you're
right I need you our home
think it's wrong your dog is looking at
me and very creepily I don't trust your
diary anymore
get in my you what yeah let's see again
my I did nothing Maya who oh hello you
feed my dog my dog my naughty or my dog
my dog I need a I need a block oh how
long does the fish run it retract damn
oh my dog is my doggies I was wondering
what the hell was going on Shawn oh heck
I was wondering what Hecker happened
okay okay forgive right now look we have
just this dirty stain right here I like
it all right so I played I fixed this
house no no if you can town it's good
it's a ceiling but yeah it's a it's a
high I've seen ceilings in my time
that's a hat I also add a one floor to
the turret upside that pyramid whoa
can you tell us all about its proper
title it's the big brain building the
big brain building that there are yeah
and people also suggested doing this so
now we have a way of getting in you ever
make something in Minecraft and then
everybody else email oh my god that is
so much easier oh thank god
I am at the corners and I didn't like it
ah corners I added the corner so we did
walk up in the corners yes I'm using a
fishing rod to cut these down okay it's
a big brain building only big brain
tactics allowed yeah exactly
frickin word big baby oh wait frickin
it's gonna get to that point
YouTube have new policies against kids
content they can't even sit Frick
anymore what can you say
blip blop blop a perception of stop are
we adding sealing or are we adding
bigger brain
what add what is the next thing to do in
the game
I don't really know get diamond armor
everyone look for diamond nether
fortress or mud potions ocean monuments
Oh fight the wither okay let's go could
we do any lapis to my agent OLAP is one
lapis so really all we have
we found one lapis we suck well we
haven't really done any of the hard work
I can make a sharpness to sword yeah
sure why not okay okay
sharpness to sweeping edge to looting
one what the heck okay so the best word
I've ever made in the game and I did it
on a level enjoy flex enough alright
okay I get it
dude you want to see my shiny Oh shiny
shiny but you don't you don't have shiny
oh let the smoke baby dude the pain
makes me stronger
bro come on bro you went too close oh
you saved me bleep luck well done the
same
yeah where's my dog but didn't you pull
me out of the fire
Oh God blip blop woohoo why didn't you
put me over the flames my ex me I'm
worried that I'm worried that you'll go
in flames last episode I was like what's
the point of getting a dog if you don't
bring them anywhere and then my episodes
are like you Sam stay there and don't
ever move if you die I cannot cope yeah
I said the series is over you can talk
this over
I gave pink the face whoa piggy likes it
he's not baked oh sorry I forgot
blip blop sorry sorry okay wait okay
yeah sweet lord
yeah but show me the trick okay you want
to see this yeah okay look straight up
okay
a little over a little over
no over here come right here right here
right here here yeah right there okay
now look straight up catch it oh it's
dark sleep time sleep sleep deep sleep
sleep
too little sleep ease okay cheap cheap
cheap cheap cheap shop okay we should
set out to do something I think it could
be closing dude don't turn around right
there's there's a mob Oh
Shippo shop Oh bleep er blah Oh poopy
poop okay we got to insult them when we
kill them oh oh oh
with no friends no okay okay
your turn your turn your turn your take
hey Greg egg egg egg okay okay okay
ready yeah
I don't realize how dumb it looks when
you bend your neck back it's not dumb
it's a tactic okay it's ready okay
oh I did wrong sorry you're right click
yeah yeah sorry I was getting message on
what's that okay
mom edit it mom why did you put a key in
here piggy come out he walked in self in
he's going frozen okay staying there
then
okay being trapped piggy have we
explored South all races so let me check
yeah which way says this way so that's
that's where we came from is it really
okay Southwest is where our portal is
because I really want to find a saddle
saddle yeah horses and what horses this
is like the natural next step we need to
give them great names I'm gonna name
mine blinky and you can name your dinky
flicky funky bleep P block P wonky
donkey
hey I caught one donkey it's a horse you
find donkeys though that'll be great
oh my god is wonky and the other ones
okay okay
super extra next step challenge in the
middle of the lake in the bra
that's impossible it that's never been
done that has never been done before but
this is why we must be the first to do
it no one in Minecraft has ever done
this before okay and you do it as well
go catch it okay catchy okay I'll catch
[Laughter]
200 messed up messed up I want to catch
it with my face I want to land any
matter right am i wait do I actually
have an arrow in my face now
no it's in your arm hit your arm dude
you weren't even close
no I felt like I was close not even a
little dude okay it's in your wrist
oh we both have risk oh my god there's
two cats really want oh I have a chicken
I mean fish okay okay she keeps a little
[ __ ] what do you what sound you make cat
[Music]
[Laughter]
keep going
[Music]
louder it can't hear you
oh no I think it scared dumb cat Oh God
do you have any more fish fishy I got
one no give it to take it then give it
quickiy
he's over there there this way that way
it's over there it's over there
that okay I got a puffer fish do they
eat pufferfish is no everyone loves
puffer fish there you are you little
snake oh they made the same noise yeah I
told you
oh this village really turn lab oh
that's why there's a cat here we're just
stealing their local can't eat the
puffer okay I'll catch him with a
fishing rod hold up stop stop stop this
Mook a blackhead yeah but we might get
more we fed this one more okay I got him
I got Kota I could okay come here
cash cash it's not dang it we need to we
need to paralyze it oh I give I give to
know what I thought they will slow it
down this is sad crying what this happen
why are you like this
Oh bonus cat there's bonus cat summer
bonus cat what are you guys doing hey
get outta there
hey don't ask why three guys they're in
a hot tub five feet apart oh my god
they're looking at me I don't like in
you fishing in there yeah so we can get
boners can't maybe you'll catch a
boyfriend oh hey here's a married man
hello can I get catch them oh right in
their brain epic write and smoke break
up a morning you ever think about how
life is just like sleep sleep eat eat
shop shop repeat repeat I know exactly
what you mean did you make a crafting
table yep how are you so fast I'll put
my next to it I have the language of the
big brain gods while you were on your
honeymoon lazing around you've been
being active in Minecraft recipes yeah
I've been studying the blade again sick
Oh took your drift
you always have to show off I can do to
show me no show me drift around me epic
we get some cool structures here but
okay well let's find a desert then and a
jungle oh as you clay I love jungler
whoa this is a crazy feeling hey can you
go up with boats no they sink ah lame so
you try to flower in the water here my
baby died so bad so sorry
oh no the Mesa plateau I don't want to
go back man oh man bad memories it's
cool though that we found that good Lord
these dolphins are nuts
stop stop why they don't listen stop it
dolphin it's lit over there is that
because we used to be there probably why
do we have no memory why did you crash
there's that whole ocean I just want to
be close to you bro bro bro
close your eyes bro what do you see bro
your face bro that's my life without you
okay we split up cover more ground
first one to find a temple wins epically
that's a terrible idea
okay let's remember where our bases okay
let's go Thunder well well well well
what dude
that's funny you laughed what are the
wells for is like outside of the village
yeah you actually found one yeah what's
that you were pulling leg I never pull
leg I have a gift
I have gift also stop by if Irish boy
okay
you are safe please accept oh thank you
accept accept my gift well you actually
have to give me food now because I'm
really actually kill me
here here book shop shop shop anymore
book shop shop I follow shop shop shop
did you follow bread trail again that's
right where's this tambourine oh look
here's a well found one go go east
oh hey I see you see Susy oh yes it's
damn this is so crazy
what there fall epic oh there is a well
well well well well well you solved the
drug problem in the desert now this land
will flourish and look I'm not very well
I'm not sure one another well solve the
problem you're free laughing here what
the heck jack follow me oh I'm not that
stupid man it's that what you fall in
love all the time shut up okay what do
we say if we see a pyramid no that's for
cats all right yeah yeah perfect okay
wahoo question mark that no that's a
well like haha
ding-dong
ah damn I almost about hood but it's a
dumb city okay Jack we gotta go in
steal their soft potatoes okay and get
hat will never see me in the grass
they'll never see his boots
oh this is good they're all ready don't
yell don't yell don't get a skeleton's
okay I think they're asleep let me go
inside watch your head here beside the
potatoes still never see me hide London
hide in the container go inside oh
that's good that's good can't see much
okay we need it if you if anything
happens just yell cook ah ah something
here it to me what is it I don't know it
hurts ow I'm starving I'm starving jack
Oh God I'm starvation Shh
I'm so hungry I my belly he ate it dude
those typically close
ever I have a really good sword imma get
him oh I found sleep deep okay I got I
got you sleep oh I found taters okay
tactical sleep okay our we're all coming
out they're all coming out oh god oh god
oh oh
cut it oh I give them poison one
let's take their Bell Bell their Messiah
[ __ ] yeah we don't have a bell at home
yeah yeah pathetic
wrong with us they have nothing you're
good sucks I say we kill them all okay
let's burn I don't have any other ways
of burning I've gone powder I kill kill
what what are you killed Oh
we swords we send message we send the
message nobody else cares in the town
things minecraft by the way this was
stuck in neighborhood sealing chores the
temple where is the temple huh you are
hiding holy temple from us we know this
okay now hit stone man okay no thanks Oh
God
you know my scheme you told me oh you
sleeved oh you sleep sleep thank god
he's sleep sleep I sleep sleep okay all
right are you ready to run in three two
hey stone man more like bone big man Oh
potential wahoo potential wahoo wahoo
question mark I'm hungry starvation
thing yep you're about to crest the
ridge bro come up onto the top of that
Ridge Road
Wow I'm so hungry
Wow Wow I'll explore without your bro
dude you would do exactly that if I was
surfing how dare you smear my name okay
so you jump down in middle right scared
the bleep out you're the brave flow man
sorry bro I can eat it thank God so much
string no no yes yes
our quest completion I wanna get rid of
tree saplings I don't care
weed seed I don't care it's golden oh I
care okay this is flippy poopy oh well
well i'ma head out I just build on
cactus bro okay I build on wood so we
have one state oh yeah a bag now we need
one more
yeah we need a horse starvation
how are you starving all the time I'm a
hungry boy give me please I don't have
anything okay well then we should
probably get some stone do you have wood
yep okay let me just dig up some so I
can make a furnace sing the cookie
cookie song cookie cookie cookie we cook
that deadly rabbit and make it feel so
yucky cookie - cookie episode is a new
right take your rabbits put a little bow
Japan boogie - Kiki what is the sound if
we find jungle temple we need to say
Oh a younger temple not your girl but a
desert temple
that's what who you idiot oh my god you
dingus
you're absolutely anything dong okay
your smallest brain I ever seen simple
commands
what if life-threatening situation and
you mix up wing young and wait which
there's a witch here Oh
weird come to me you've already went in
without me
yeah and dude I have a gift for you
check this bro how do you not see that
hey can you have oh you mean materials
bro
it's almost like you raid the temple
without your bro dude I left you two
good things at straight-up SETI in your
spaghetti okay Patrick I like that one
oh you said too much yeah next No
oh man where are you
but where are your stuff I tried to
protect oh I see it I protect it and I
grab your XP no problem it's okay as
long as someone has it I avenged you as
well all right i'ma head out I do that
to you say something in a like I have to
reference it can you can you sleep
anywhere I have a you want to sleep
sleep
I kind of want to sleep sleep alright
but this bed is occupied okay
spiders swore yes but not gonna edit
that out dude everyone's gonna know oh
god no yeah every bed free yeah I mean
just like me okay get him get him tired
man okay sleep dataview sleep sleep
sleep sleep sleep kill pie husk Musk
okay grab the bed cuz we might need it
alright we should head back if you guys
are blue key cookie then tune in next
time to see us get our f
horse is whoa really this for 12 years
yeah
yes you can come up with this wahoo no
you need to say like epically I'm gonna
stick with woohoo
well you haven't tried to pursue me
later today after 50 million a fruit fly
ash down just down it's still relevant
just down a bit